i mean you can give up temporal freedom
and get a high-paying job and make a
bunch of money and then you have
economic freedom you can give up the
sort of safety and stability and
predictability of living in a modern
society and go into the wilderness and
you have the freedom of that but you're
in a fair amount of danger and if
something happens to you like you have a
ruptured appendix sorry guy you're dead
you never get all forms of freedom at
once
[Music]
a little while ago you had a near-death
experience what was the story behind
that
yeah i mean you know i've been in a lot
of combat as a journalist with american
soldiers and and and and otherwise
around the world and
i thought all you know sort of danger
was behind me i'm in good health i'm an
athlete i'm in good shape i have i got a
heart rate of 60 and blood pressure 120
over 80 and everything you could want at
age 50
58 last year uh
and i felt a sudden pain in my abdomen
and it was an undiagnosed
aneurysm
in my pancreatic artery which is this
like little artery that nobody thinks
about and had an aneurysm and it
ruptured and i started bleeding out into
my own into my own abdomen and by the
time they got me to the er
i'd lost three quarters of my blood
and uh you know when women often when
women die in childbirth which tragically
still happens
they're basically they're dying the same
way they're bleeding to death and they
can't find the they can't find the the
bleed and they can't stop it and they
lose the woman and that's basically what
was happening to me but it was the
result of an of a ruptured aneurysm and
um
you know by by the time they were they
were they were cutting my neck open to
put a line into my jugular to get enough
blood into me fast enough to save me by
the time that was happening uh you know
i was i was actively dying and my you
know i'm an atheist i'm not religious my
dad was a physicist but my dead father
appeared above me he started welcoming
me which is some an experience i'm still
struggling to explain and uh
and a black pit opened up underneath me
and i was getting pulled into it and
you know it was the
i i mean i guess neurologically the
black pit of unconsciousness i don't
know but it was a very
uh it's not like falling asleep it's not
like losing consciousness when you're
having about to have a medical procedure
i was getting pulled into a black hole
and my dead father was there and the
last thing i said to the doctor was you
gotta hurry you're losing me right now
and um they
you know they did their work their
amazing work and they saved me and um
you know i was touch and go for a while
because i need they needed another eight
hours to find the leak inside me and
um you know when you're transfused like
that i had 10 units of blood and when
you're transfused like that
you know other problems happen like you
start to get you run the risk of organ
failure and
and and things like that and and luckily
i'm healthy and my body
managed to
stay alive for eight hours until they
they fixed the leak and
i'm very very lucky to be here most
people die from this and i'm very lucky
to be here
that's an insane story i have a friend
that i met last year in dubai and he had
he was put under a
induced coma for three months or so and
during that time he lived an entire
another life for two years in singapore
and he could tell you
the name of the company that he had the
brand of toothpaste he put on his
toothbrush where his ties were kept
inside of his apartment he would be able
to tell you the name of the street that
he went to and he was selling virtual
reality software in this other life and
he was testing it on himself he had a
full team he had a sales team he had
developers and he would go into
the experience the virtual reality
experience inside of this other world
while he's laid in a hospital bed and he
doesn't know he would go into it and he
would hear people talking and at one
point he gets trapped inside of the
virtual reality world for two months
inside of this dream so this is like two
layers down of inception and in that he
can hear people speaking to him and he
doesn't know what it is and then
eventually he gets his fingers into a
corner and prys it apart and that's when
he wakes up but during this other world
that he lives in for two years while
he's away for about three months his
father dies so his dad his dream father
dies while his real father's still alive
and they're watching him while he's in
bed paul
in bed
in this induced coma and they see that
he's weeping he's got tears streaming
out the corner of his eyes and that's
when he's burying his dead father in the
dream while his real father watches him
cry about the fact that he's had to do
it
crazy
that's insane did he ever go to
singapore to look up the places he
had thought you know imagined he was
like i don't think he has no
wow that's insane
there's a lot of you know again i'm an
atheist i feel like i have to keep
saying this uh but there's a lot of
things we don't understand and and i i'm
very open to the idea that there are
dimensions of reality that we don't
understand or haven't even guessed at
and that in those threats in these
threshold states like in a coma
uh or in uh in a um sort of um
transportative religious an ecstatic
religious state or something yeah
yeah that we sort of like gained some
sort of like entry
in some glimpse into another another
dimension of reality i i can understand
how that would be true
um and i think my father the physicist
would also say yes there's things we
don't understand and that means that
there are phenomena that we can't
explain
even if there isn't some other
worldliness going on even if it's not a
different plane that you're tapping into
sheer the sheer fact that your brain
decided to create some sort of
kind of like a polarity thing it's sort
of welcoming there's something symbolic
going on with regards to darkness and
father and and then with paul this
near-death experience
in an induced coma is
semi-common it's it's like rarely common
um and
even if all it was was the brain trying
to create some sort of an existence in
which he could keep taking over even if
that's it like just that is pretty
miraculous itself
yeah
well my understanding of the medical
understanding of an induced coma is that
there's no brain activity at all so i
wonder how that basically
you know i wonder how they uh understand
that but likewise with death you know
like that there's no brain activity and
i you know i mean i was entering a very
strange place and when i was on that
threshold
and um you know i've done some research
into it and and
my experience is a very common one and
it's interesting because they have there
are various neurological explanations
like low blood oxygen
um uh endogenous dmt in your brain that
gets released um
and ketamine endogenous ketamine that
gets released things that will produce
visions and hallucinations
in in test subjects but when they when
they expose people to those
effects like ketamine
people have wild hallucinations they
don't see the dead they don't see
dead relatives right you have to be
dying
for that to happen
and um and that that's the part that
it's it's very common for people who are
dying and it's
not really part of the ketamine
experience for otherwise healthy people
and that's where the mystery sort of
begins for me yeah i am familiar from my
days partying i'm pretty familiar with
ketamine and i never saw any of my dead
parents coming back even though both of
them were alive
which means is it set and setting which
is something that psychedelics
researchers talk about is it the fact
that you've been primed because you feel
like you're about to die so that there's
some sort of predisposition toward
thinking that this is the sort of
vision that you may have or is there
maybe
something else going on is it a blend of
other sort of chemicals
pretty interesting
yeah i mean i didn't know i was dying so
i i mean i was shocked yeah of course
you just thought that you were
no i mean i said i said to the doctor
you're losing me right now
and i meant i felt myself getting pulled
away but i had no idea that i was dying
it never crossed my mind i mean i just
had a tummy ache right and i felt funny
i mean i did and you know my i was
pretty loopy because i had i had a
um
uh
uh you know my blood oxygen levels were
incredibly low my hemoglobin was 1.2 i
mean it's hard to find that
on the internet right i mean almost no
one goes that low that that's inco
that's incompatible with life right is
what i was told 1.2 hemoglobin
hemoglobin is what transports oxygen so
basically i mean i was running on fumes
and uh i had no idea that i was dying
the next day that the nurse in the icu
said we no one knows how you made it
like you almost died yesterday no one
knows why you're still here it was
completely shocking to me so maybe
there's some kind of body knowledge
that understands you're dying on a kind
of animal level and produces the
appropriate hallucinations entirely
possible
or there's something weird going on in
reality and there's something we don't
understand about death and that
you know dead people have some
dimension of existence
that we don't we don't understand that
we that we ourselves access on the
threshold of death i mean i i don't know
you know but it's a it's a it's a
legitimate question didn't you say that
there were a couple of things that had
occurred
weird embodied senses sort of
subconsciously things that you'd gone
through in the time period leading up to
that incident as well
yeah i mean for many years i for no
reason that i can identify and i'm a i
was an endurance athlete when i was
young i'm very for
for a person of my age i'm very healthy
i'm sorry high performance human you
know and
and uh
um
for many but for many years i i i had
this bizarre certainty that i would die
before i was 60. you know and i'm not
really eligible for you know a heart
attack or a stroke or something like
that you know i just have a constitution
that makes that very unlikely
um
i don't know why and that's exactly what
would have happened but for this sort of
miracle but but also like two days
before
um i was woken up by a nightmare
that i had died and i'd crossed over and
i was looking back at my family and they
were grieving and i couldn't go back to
them because i'd crossed over and i was
just like anguished i i
have two little girls you know four at
the time they were three and one and i
was abs and my wife and i was completely
anguished that i'd sort of screwed up
and had died sort of by accident and uh
and i couldn't i couldn't go back again
and i was anguished and it woke me up
and that was 36 hours before
exactly that
happened crazy given the fact that you
had such a profound experience
has there been a lasting
mindset
shift around how you see the world or a
change in your behavior in any way
well you know i'm i'm i'm a little bit
more open to you know what
you might call the great mystery of life
and of death you know a little a little
more open to
the idea that it may not be
that we might be something more than
purely biological beings
and that are
everything that that we are ends at the
moment of death uh
i mean you know i've seen dead bodies
i've seen people who were dead an hour
i've seen people who were dead a week
i've seen people who are dead a month
right it's hard to imagine when you look
at
those individuals that there's anything
remaining of that what who that person
was right i can tell you right now like
it just wow you're some skin and a bunch
of bones like you are no longer you
right so
that but now i'm not sure like i
i just don't understand what happened to
me and people keep saying to me like
uh
well
you know are you reconsidering your
atheism you know like uh you know i'm
and i'm like i didn't see god i saw my
father you know like i don't know god
doesn't necessarily have anything to do
with this but there the presence of my
father does raise questions about the
nature of reality in a physical sense
and the nature of death in a physical
sense and um
so
uh other than that you know i would say
i mean it's sort of cliche but all we
know we have for sure is right and
we don't even know that we have today we
we know we have this moment
right this moment that you and i are
both in right now we know for sure we
have that because we're in it
and
literally moment by moment we you cannot
absolutely know that even the next
moment will come much less the day the
next day will come right you don't know
there was a lady
about a week ago
who was woken up
she was asleep and she was woken up
because of meteor the size it was set it
was set up but it seems quite gendered
so it's a sort of funny but this was in
the media
a meteor the size of a large man's fist
i just find that in this modern era
quite a funny way to describe a meteor
but anyway a meteor the size of a large
man's fist
walloped into the pillow next to her
head
right she was three inches from being
annihilated right and uh
yeah so
um
uh or she came to bed and found it there
i don't know which it was but at any
rate had her had been there like she
would be dead so you don't know moment
to moment that you would but right in
this moment right now you do you know
exist you know you exist and in this
sort of zen sense that is all we know
for sure that we have and so it makes me
just think you know be in the moment
like appreciate the fact that you are
alive right now right here with your
little girls
or whatever like who you are right now
and just have a reverence for that
because that's all you ever know that
you have for sure
if that's what you get out of a
near-death experience overall i think
avoiding the near-death experience would
probably have been preferable but that
realization is pretty beautiful another
crazy thing which is what i said to my
friend on the podcast paul about the
fact that he buried his father once and
he was going to have to bury him again
um you're potentially going to see
your father and that sort of black pit
again at some point you may sort of
glance off the top of that once and then
come back around for a second loop at
some point and then see it again i you
know i was taken to the threshold and
then brought back and so i now know what
that that is like that place is like and
i gotta say i did not want to go down
there
um but it seemed like a a minor
transition it didn't seem like this
massive like oh my god i'm dying like it
seemed
in that moment
it seemed like
well that whatever that next thing is
it's a small step to the left
it's not a huge thing it's a small thing
and by the time you're dying
death is a
small transition right
and
dying is a
you know it it it
it's a vague thing right i mean when
you're dying your body is shutting down
but there's no moment
right where you just get
you get less and less alive and more and
more dead right up into the point where
you're almost completely dead and very
little bit alive and then that last
little bit seems to be a minor step and
and there was some
you know funny way it took the it took a
bit of the mystery out of it i mean
a bit of the awe out of it it's like oh
death it's just it it's it's a very
mundane thing
you know it's like it it
i mean it's it's it's an ordinary thing
right it's a it's a very ordinary thing
that everybody does and it's
it's not some transcendent thing it
could just be part of what happened
during your day you know i mean it was a
very strange perspective on it
talking about freedom today and
you went from someone who
i guess from the outside looking in as a
a single guy
in his late 40s early 50s would have had
all of the freedom in the world but then
started a family had
two young daughters got married talk me
through that experience as someone who's
done it later in life
yeah i mean i was so i was married
previously uh
and um you know my wife and i were still
friends my ex-wife and i are still
friends we broke up on very good terms
and and remain sort of like
loyal to each other as friends
throughout that process thank god and uh
i'm very grateful to her for that um
but during the the trek that i undertook
i was going through that process of
separation and divorce and it was very
sad very sad year and um
i was why i should just sort of describe
it briefly so my million and a few
buddies we'd all been in a lot of combat
either as soldiers or as journalists
we walked along the railroad lines
from washington dc to philadelphia to
pittsburgh about 400 miles the railroad
lines in this country are these sort of
swaths of no man's land that are really
not patrolled
or monitored by the authorities and um
you can kind of do what you want out
there and you know it's a dangerous
environment right i mean there are
trains going by at 120 miles an hour
um
and
whatever they're marginal environments
there are some drifty kind of people out
there whatever you but it goes through
everything right the suburbs
and the farms and the wilderness and the
ghettos and the industrial wasteland it
goes through everything and we were
sleeping under bridges and in abandoned
buildings and cooking over fires
and um
getting our water out of creeks and
dodging the police uh because it's
illegal of course and
um you know most nights as i say in the
book
my book freedom most like nights we were
the only people in the world who knew
where we were
and that's a form of freedom and uh and
one that's not to be sneezed at and
although there's many other forms as
well but but um
you know after that yes i i
found myself in a very very good
relationship with a wonderful wonderful
woman and um and we decided that
i'm trying to have a family and we were
lucky we were blessed and that we that
it happened and we have two little girls
and you know i've had all kinds of other
freedom
prior in my life
you know my first daughter was born at
age 55 and
um you know one of the reasons i try to
stay very healthy and athletic is gonna
because i want to stay
alive as long as possible possible for
them
and for me for them you know and and uh
so
i i
i felt like i was giving up yeah you're
giving up one kind of freedom and you're
getting another kind of freedom but
that's always true
right i mean you can give up
you know temporal freedom and get a
high-paying job and make a bunch of
money and then you have economic freedom
uh you can give up
you know
you can give up the sort of safety and
stability and predictability of living
in a modern society and go into the
wilderness
and you have the freedom of that but
you're in a fair amount of danger and if
something happens to you like you have a
ruptured appendix sorry guy you're dead
you know like
so there's you never get all forms of
freedom at once and the form of freedom
that i got as
you know as a father as a as a
husband and father
is this profound emotional freedom of be
a
of love
you know and and and uh you know in some
ways it's the most un
the most boundless form of freedom there
is and it has no limits no depths you
know it's as boundless as as it's only
limited by you and uh
and that and you know there's something
about that that that you know maybe it
would have been lost on me at age 20 or
30 or whatever and that's probably good
i wasn't the dad back then
but
thank god i'm a dad now because i
thought i you know at this point i would
have wondered what's life for
that's a beautiful story it's a really
really beautiful story to hear
thank you thank you you say that there's
a tension between freedom and community
how does that play out
well you are not um you're not safe
unless you're part of a group i mean
just in sort of like biological terms
anthropological terms humans do not
survive alone in nature they die almost
immediately we survive
as a biological matter we survive
because we're part of a group we don't
have sharp claws we don't have sharp
teeth we can't climb trees very well we
can't we can't run very fast
although on hot days we can run run
quite far which makes us different than
from from most other mammals but
um
we get our safety or our physical safety
and therefore emotional safety from
being part of a group a survival group
and
uh that means that if you're part of a
group
you have to participate you have to
contribute and you have to abide by
group norms
and you know if you're in a
hunter-gatherer group 50 000 years ago
and you were a young male
that the group norm probably expected
you to be part of the effort to hunt
food
right
and to defend the community with
violence with force if necessary from a
predator or from a group of another
group of progressive humans that was
your job right
and if you were not willing to do that
you were not fulfilling your your
expected role in that community and you
were cast out undoubtedly you were cast
out and i so i looked at the american
frontier in pennsylvania in the 1700s
these the early settlers that went into
what was called indian territory you
know escaped the sort of control and
oppression maybe of the colonial
government and uh and of the of the
church of that era to the wilderness
right it's god god's god's world god's
great land right and but the problem is
the wilderness was enormously free and
enormously dangerous and the way that
they
re reduced those risks the settlers was
by having basically a a mutual defense
pact among the sort of families in every
area they would build a stockade
and if there was a sort of like if they
if there were indian raids
um everyone would collect at the
stockade and defend it and if you were a
boy aged 14 or over you were expected to
carry a rifle
and and use it and fight in defense of
the group
women had roles as well uh of course
equally vital roles
and um they would reload the weapons
they would they would attend the wounded
they would try to put out the fires that
were started by flaming arrows in the
rooms of the buildings right so if
you're not willing to do those things
you were not wanted right
you you know welcome to you know you're
welcome to leave now like if you're not
willing to help defend the group so
these settlers got a great freedom in
the wilderness but
they had to abide by the norms of the
group they were not free
to act selfishly within within the group
and likewise you know i would say just a
very mundane level
like
we are a america is a free country in
many important regards but you are not
free to drive on the left-hand side of
the road as you do in in england in
america in the united states you drive
on the right-hand side of the road if
you try the left-hand side of the road
you're going to kill somebody or if you
run a red light you're going to kill
somebody you're not free to do that you
have to abide by the norms of this
particular group which in this case is a
community of 330 million people all whom
agree that we'll all drive on the
right-hand side of the road to keep
highway deaths to a minimum
is there a pretty particularly unique
tension now that previously
the symbiotic relationship between the
individual and the group had to work a
little bit more hard because the
individual could not survive
without adhering to the rules of the
group whereas now we have a much more
fragmented society that's a lot safer
you don't necessarily need to yeah
there's some laws that you need to but
there's the individual has more power as
convenience and safety is increased well
they they have you know they can indulge
in the illusion that they don't need the
group but you know we're all putting
gasoline into our cars that is drilled
by other people we're eating food that
other people grew we're living in homes
for the most part that other people
built uh we're we're dependent we're
outsourcing our our defense and survival
needs to the fire department and to
uh doctors and nurses and
uh to the police and to soldiers for
that matter and you know
every every every survival task that
confronted
uh
um
small-scale organic societies
in modern society has been outsourced
right so you don't grow your own food
but at you know you have to be at work
at 9am and you work till 5pm and maybe
you're maybe you're paid half a million
dollars a year or maybe you're paid 30
000 whatever it is
maybe you're doing well or not well
within that system
but that system is providing your basic
survival needs and in return you're
giving it your time right you're not
temporarily free
right but you're free from the sort of
most immediate threats to your survival
uh at least in sort of evolutionary
human terms um so the idea that you're
like oh i'm i you know i'm an american
citizen and i don't need anybody i'm
blah blah blah like just complete
nonsense right listen man the gun you're
carrying that you're
you're the gun that you're like showing
up at the state house with
to show what a badass you are and how
free you are that gun was made by
somebody else the ammo is made by
somebody else the pickup truck you drove
down
you know drove down there was made by
somebody else and the gasoline that's in
the tank was made by somebody else you
were not free at all and humans never
have been we have never existed alone in
nature we live in groups the group that
we all live in in modern society is an
extremely large complicated group with a
huge supply chain that is so complicated
that it really needs some kind of like
federal oversight and regulation to keep
it running well and countries that don't
have that like somalia or afghanistan
the supply chain is very unreliable
there's a black market economy that's
extremely exploitative and there's a
huge amount of corruption so you know
like if you think you're doing not doing
well in this country with federal
oversight go to somalia you you you will
be blessed with no federal oversight see
how it goes
what do you class as the opposite of
freedom because some people would say
like tyranny or something but i'm
guessing that's maybe a little bit rough
hewn
well i mean again uh
i mean i hope i'm not sort of hiding
behind you know anthropology and biology
but in in uh in long-standing human
terms the most immediate threat to your
freedom was an enemy group that would
come in and kill or enslave you right
that was the most immediate
uh threat to the to your freedom
and by you i mean you and your community
right you and your tribe
uh
you and your and your loved ones um the
word freedom
is is taken from the middle german uh
freedom
which means beloved
so
in that sense
people who were free
were the people around you in your
community the the people who were
beloved by you
and strangers
foreigners
outsiders
did not necessarily have the right to
freedom right i mean if you could
kill and enslave them they were your
slaves right i mean they like they
didn't have
there was no international law right
there was no human rights law there was
no international standards like that of
human rights and human dignity
basically the only people you were you
could not morally
kill or enslave were people within your
own community the term murder applied to
those people
killing the enemy was not murder right
that was killing the enemy
and so freedom the essential meaning of
freedom is that the people you and your
beloved your community
are without an
outside oppressor
right which means you can oppress other
people but you yourselves are not being
oppressed right that's the meaning of
the word freedom so so so in the modern
world i would say we still have to pay
through homage to that original meaning
if you are safe from the predations of
an outside enemy group you are in a very
very important sense free the way you do
that is being a well-armed
well-organized state that can repel
the
the attacks of an invader the the
of an aggressor but if you're well armed
enough and well organized enough to to
defeat the enemy
then an abusive leader
has an apparatus a security apparatus
that is well armed and well organized
enough to oppress his own people to
basically turn his own people into serfs
which is what the elite of europe did
throughout the entire
medieval era right i mean the the era
observed them that essentially that
essentially ended with the enlightenment
and then with the revolutions in france
and america and elsewhere
that system
um was one of elite power and
uh
and and essentially served them every
people had no legal rights he couldn't
sue the king right the king could kill
you and you had no your family had no
recourse
uh you could rape and plunder and
pillage as much as you wanted if you
were royalty right there was no
democracy brought an end to that and the
laws that applied to the commoners to
everyone also apply to the to the elites
um obviously democracy falls a little
bit short on that but but at least in
theory that was that was the idea so
that's how you keep
i mean basically there's freedom from an
oppressor
and out there's freedom from an enemy
and then there's freedom from an
oppressor within your own society and
what democracy tries to do
is have a well-equipped state that can
defend itself and have a system of laws
that defends the populist populace
against
an unscrupulous
ruler
so you've got three uh identifiers for
ways that
people and groups can become free as in
run
fight and think but it sounds like
coordinating is actually the first thing
that everybody needs to do there's a
there's a pre-step to all of that
well yeah i mean societies coordinate
right i mean that's what a society is so
that's just taken as a given
um
but uh there is no state of human
evolution where a bunch of individual
individuals are like oh this isn't
working on our own out here in the
jungle let's get together and do this
that never happened right i mean we our
closest relatives are chimpanzees
um we we split from the from chimpanzees
about six million years ago
uh 99
some or 98 of our dna is
indistinguishable from chimpanzee dna uh
we're very very closely related to them
we are social primates and always have
been so in my book freedom what i wanted
to figure out was how do humans alone
among mammals
maintain their their autonomy their
freedom in the face of a larger more
powerful foe
um so individual combatants
a smaller man can defeat a larger man i
mean one of the interesting things about
mixed martial arts and its early days is
that they had no weight categories and
there are plenty of examples of smaller
smaller fighters who handily defeated
larger larger adversaries inconceivable
in the primate world right in the rest
of the primate world you know likewise
smaller coalitions can defeat larger
coalitions the montenegrins in the 1600s
um
a wild mountain tribe were invaded by
the ottoman empire one of the dominant
militaries of the era the the
montenegrins were outnumbered 12 to one
right that the ottomans had cavalry
artillery you know all the advantages
that america had in fighting the taliban
and the montenegrins handed them their
hat right i mean they that over and over
again they defeated the ottomans and
expelled them from their land and
um inconceivable except for human so i
was trying to figure out how does this
work so basically
the first
a a a a underdog group the first thing
that they try to do when they're dealing
with an oppressor is outrun them so the
apache in the american southwest unlike
the pueblo societies that were rooted in
place because they're agriculturalists
they were much more wealthy they were
sedentary they didn't have the option of
fleeing they were rolled by the spanish
immediately sometimes within hours of
the confrontation they
they were defeated or surrendered to the
spanish where the apache maintained
after first contact the apache
maintained their autonomy for another
three centuries right almost to within
my my grandmother's life right my
grandmother was born in 1900 there were
there were bands of free apache who
survived almost until 1900 right because
they were mobile they were free
um but if you can't outrun your enemy
you're gonna have to out fight it
and that's where this amazing dynamic
comes in that with humans
um either on one-on-one combat or or in
coalitionary combat the smaller group
the smaller individual can actually win
um which means that larger groups like
the united states eventually you know
winds up negotiating with with smaller
groups like the taliban
i hate the taliban they're loathsome
right no respect for women's rights for
human rights
um but i gotta say if the smaller group
always lost there would no there would
be no freedom in the human experience
the world would be composed of large
fascist mega states that impose their
will on everybody else that's not what
the world looks like
um and then finally
if you're within a society you know this
is this is how you deal with it and you
know enemies right you run or you fight
but how do you deal with oppression
within your own society if you're being
oppressed by the government or business
interests or what have you
how do you what do you do you have to
out think them you're now in a chess
game right you're not going to run away
and and you can't defeat them in
outright combat
how do you do it so i looked at the
labor movement
uh in the united states about 100 years
ago
i looked at the easter rising in dublin
and in ireland in 1916 around the same
era
um you you know these th these are
groups that are completely outgunned by
the power the established powers you
know military government and corporate
power is completely outgunned and yet
they managed to
eventually
achieve their purposes and uh
one way one very important thing to do i
looked at successful underdog groups and
one thing they had in common is they
often incorporate women
um not necessarily into the front lines
of combat but into the sort of matrix
of the revolutionary movement the
insurgency
women have lateral networks
uh men are very top-down hierarchical
that's very important when it comes to
charging machine guns uh
it's essential
but women's lateral networks are also
very important because they're almost
impossible for
the the state for the authority the
authorities to to penetrate to
infiltrate um to decapitate you can't do
it it's a lateral network like a spider
web very very important and the other
thing
is that women on a you know sort of
honor on a in a social movement you put
women on the front lines of a strike or
a protest it makes it very very hard for
the police to use force
they will of course it happens uh
but there there is a sanction against
violent using violent mass violence
public mass violence against women that
isn't quite as strong as it is for men a
group of men
uh protesting in the street look like a
mob
a group of women protesting in the
street they look like a social movement
and you open up with the machine guns on
them and it's very problematic for the
uh
for the government for the dictatorship
whatever it may be
and so this the in the labor movement in
lawrence massachusetts in in uh
in 1912
uh they were confronting national guard
with fixed bayonets and
the men were sort of powerless to
confront this show of force so they
started putting women on the front line
of the protests and these young boys in
uniform with fixed bayonets did not know
what to do they're looking at women just
like their sisters and their mothers or
maybe their daughters right and
and one frustrated police captain said
he said one one one good cop can handle
10 men
but it takes 10 cops to handle one woman
and they did not quite have the manpower
to handle those protests and that tipped
the balance um
and the other thing that these underdog
groups having successful underdog groups
have in common is leaders that are
willing to die for the cause
uh literally willing to die for the
cause and
um if you don't have that if you have
leadership that's sort of hiding behind
the people that they lead either
literally or figuratively uh leaders who
will not accept blame who will not take
risk
who will who will not own mistakes
uh who will not expose themselves to
gunfire if it's actually a shooting
situation you have leaders like that
they're really not leaders they're
opportunists it does not work
yeah there's you see this echo
symbolically in stories and in movies as
well the leader of the goody side is
always the guy that's charging into
battle he'll stay behind to help the
wounded man and carry him on his
shoulder whereas the leader of the
baddies he's always up in some ivory
tower commanding people around and then
it's the good guy that will eventually
rise up the lift and fight through all
of the layers and then eventually get to
this bourgeois [ __ ] that someone someone
needs to kill so yeah you see this you
see this happen what was the story with
was it michael malin that you looked at
mean michael mallon was an irish
revolutionary in 1916 who
commanded a brigade in dublin
um and um
you know was eventually caught i mean
there was a after a week of uh
after a week of combat in in dublin um
in bloody combat a lot of people died
uh and you know the brits were throwing
soldiers at the problem you know by the
thousands and the the rebels who we had
machine guns and were like hiding you
know you know sort of in in in you know
in sandbag departments you know they
figured this out they were just mowing
down these poor team british teenagers
um
conscripts and you know but you know
this is the same the same era when um
you know they the the british lost
60 000 men on the first day of the
battle of the sun something like that
killed and wounded if i'm remembering my
numbers correctly it was the population
of county wicklow in ireland and one day
that was just the first day and nobody
blinked right so human life
you know didn't mean anything and i'm
sure the irish rebels were like jesus if
they treat their own people like that
how are they going to treat us we don't
want to be part of this fiasco right so
so michael mallon was one of the leaders
and i think he had four children and he
uh was married and had four children and
you know he was tried as sort of a
sham trial and uh not allowed any
representation and condemned to
death for treason
uh and on his way to the jail where they
would uh
where they would kill him he passed the
wagon
past his home and he saw his was not
done on purpose
i don't know
i don't know
um
uh and and he uh
he saw his dog in the yard and he there
there are these
anguish letters that he wrote in the
hours before his day his family was
allowed to visit him
in the on his last night
and um then he was left
alone
in his cell
with god presumably he was very
religious
and in my book i have uh printed in full
is his last
desperate letter of of anguish to his
wife and and children
um and the first sign of
light and dawn at dawn they took him
from his cell
and walked him down to the stone
breaker's yard
and stood in before a wall
and uh
a firing squad leveled their rifles and
on command they fired in unis
unison and killed them and and the
medical examiner you know they killed i
think 12 or 14 irish revolutionaries
like this
um
and uh including a man named connolly
who who was the commander of the dublin
dublin forces that fought the brits and
you know he was wounded twice i mean
that you know the big job that his aides
had was the dragging you know trying to
drag him out of gunfire you know because
he kept risking his life to command the
troops i mean he was the epitome of
heroic heroic leadership right and he
was shot twice wounded twice
and and he couldn't even walk to his own
death when they executed him they had to
carry him in a stretcher and prop him up
in a chair and and the medical examiner
that was present at these executions
said that the only people in the
situation that were not nervous
they were not shaking were that
condemned the condemned men and the
firing squads were all shaking they were
so nervous they were the fearful ones
and uh
um
and you know i should i should say um
i should say that this
what you said about you know this sort
of like
hollywood movies about villains being
these sort of bourgeois [ __ ] in a tower
you know well getting other men to do
their bidding
um
and and on the good side there's like a
selfless leader that
um
that you know grabs the flag and charges
forward as it were
you know what what we're depicting in
the bad guys is our own society i mean
that is exactly what our leaders are
they're ensconced in safe buildings
telling other people what to do
and you know i get it it's a modern
society and no one wants
the president himself leading the charge
you know i mean it just wouldn't work
right i mean it just i mean
you know like with like with connolly
you know we you know we need those
people to to help run the show so you
don't want them taking a bullet that you
know that's for soldiers to do but i
totally get it but but just to your
point about what the sort of bad guys
look like they look like we make them
look like us
and they have leaders i feel like
political leaders in
in modern european
western democracies including america
um are sort of notable for their for
their moral cowardice you know i mean
they they you know they there is no
principle they weren't they won't
trample
to further their political interests
well that's the equivalent the
equivalent of not taking the bullet is
standing by your word you don't need to
stand in front of the gunfire but if you
are to say a thing
you need to not
forget that you said that thing three
weeks later and pretend that you said
something else and try and spin a
different line out i think this is one
of the reasons why we have concerns
about the
trustworthiness of the people at the top
yeah i mean you know i would vote for
someone who was willing to
uh
uh lose an election because
he or she felt that the truth was
necessary to articulate so liz cheney
i'm a democrat right liz cheney is very
conservative
and she is standing up
to the you know the sort of like mega
donald trump world
by insisting on reality right insisting
on the truth about january 6 and about
donald trump's efforts to subvert the
election and
and you know i would vote for her even
though i'm a democrat i would vote for
her she's an arch conservative i would
vote for her simply because she is
willing to sacrifice her career for the
sake of the truth and our democracy and
our democratic system i would vote for
her over a democrat who was not willing
to tell the truth in a heartbeat right
and but that's the
um that is now the standard for for
courage is are you willing to tell the
truth and i feel like a lot of
politicians actually won't even pass
that standard it's pathetic it's a
pretty low bar
it's a low bar right it's absolutely
pathetic and if there weren't such
enormous financial rewards for being in
government i mean mitch mcconnell has 10
million dollars in the bank where the
hell did mitch mcconnell get 10 million
bucks right i mean i'm not sure he got
saying he got that illegally but there's
a a sort of aspect of unseemliness that
you have people who are exploiting
dianne feinstein uh a democrat also like
completely violated ethics rules about
insider stock trading right and
um i i mean 37 i think it was 37
congress men and women have violated uh
and i'm getting this from russell brand
by the way so you can go check it you
can go check it but i just interviewed
with him a few days ago that i looked up
some of his busy videos so assuming that
he has his facts right i'm sure he does
37 american congressmen and women have
violated their own ethics standards
about insider stock training their own
standards that a law that they
themselves passed 37 right
that's not ethical right that's immoral
and that and people like that forget
about being able to benefit financially
they shouldn't be anywhere near off uh a
public office if they're willing to do
that i mean that's what okay you don't
have to take a bullet that's you know
politics don't involve literally
fighting the enemy in the trenches right
but at the very least
you can go forego the opportunity to
enrich yourself for four years at the
very least you can do that for us and
they're not even rising to that it's a
severe distance from the philosopher
king of the marcus aurelius era you know
you think about somebody who's concerned
with virtue above all others that will
sell the inside of the palace wares to
try and pay off the debts of the nation
yeah i mean
i think this is why for me
politics feels like such a wasted
endeavor that
the
understanding of how to olympically
hijack the electorate has taken
precedent over people actually doing
what is good like being able to
manipulate cognitive biases means that
someone who isn't good can appear more
good than someone who is
that's that's unfortunately the
situation that we're in
yeah absolutely and
you know when if you live in a sort of
small scale organic survival group of 30
40 50 people as humans have done for
most of their 200 000 years of existence
it's very easy to detect fraud to detect
that kind of duplicity that kind of
dishonesty and cowardice and it's
usually punished by death i mean there's
an anthropologist named richard boehm
who looked at the application of capital
punishment within hunter-gatherer
societies right
and the most common reason
for
killing one's leader as a hunter get in
a hunter-gatherer community
um in modern-day
hunter-gatherer societies and what is
known from the last hundred years of
anthropology in these societies the most
common reason by far was abuse
when leaders abuse their position of
power and and um and work to benefit
themselves ahead of other people
um i know that there were tribes native
native tribes in in
in america
uh
you know 100 plus years ago um
where
cowardice you know a warrior who was who
who
was
cowardly on the battlefield
um was killed
by his fellow warriors like you were a
coward man you didn't defend the tribe
sorry like
we're gonna do you a favor you've
dishonored yourself we're going to do
you we're going to spare you having to
kill yourself we're going to do it for
you right
that's leadership that's selflessness
that is acting on behalf of your tribe
and
and
lead you know political leaders now
that's not even on the menu right so how
do we mod how do we patrol that that
behavior monitor that behavior we're not
in groups of 30 40 50 people or 100
people or 500 people we're in groups of
millions and millions and you know what
it used to be there was a great thesis
that the modern 50 that the monotheistic
god was invented
during the advent of agriculture when
surplus food allowed great numbers of
people to live together basically there
were communities of strangers
you know anonymity was possible right
after the advent of agriculture and that
was when the monotheistic god was sort
of invented
to
and all all seeing all knowing punitive
god
who
would punish sin right so the community
might not know who you are and you steal
a loaf of bread and you get away with it
because no one knows who you are you
know whatever but god knows who you are
it's a monotheistic all-knowing god
that was invented to control to to to
encourage good behavior in a society
that was so large there was anonymity
but now we're basically a godless
society you know i'm an atheist so you
know i get it so what do we have in this
place you know we have cctv you know
basically it's very hard to commit a
public crime
um without it being captured on video
and thank god right because there are
lots of very very bad people done very
bad things
including the the uh
you know the london underground bombers
of 2004 you know who were you know one
of them was captured because there he
was seen
he was seen on
uh on cctv cameras so they're a good you
know they're a good thing they've taken
the place of a monotheistic theistic guy
so what but what do we do now is the
electorate how do we how do we get
people to act that way we get them to
act that way
by penalizing at the at the
at the polling booth penalizing selfish
behavior dishonest behavior you know we
have to call it out and we have to call
it out in our own party because we call
it out in the other party everyone's
going to ignore it we have to call it
out among ourselves among our own and
that's something that the democrats and
the republicans are uniquely bad at
and and
the country
it's not going to be an honest system
until those two parties decide to apply
some real morality to their own people
yeah game theoretically it doesn't sound
like a good strategy to stop focusing on
the enemy and start focusing on the
inside but that's without the luxury of
a god's eye view if you were to say look
i want the best sort of world community
nation that i can do you need to hold
everybody to account not just the
opposition to try and get yourselves
back into power to do what to have four
more years of shitty power that's not
going to get you very far thinking about
the uh people riding into battle i heard
a story about a spartan soldier who was
incredibly proficient he was one of the
finest soldiers in the army and he went
into battle naked so he stripped off all
of his armor stripped off all of his
clothes just went in shield sword and
spear and when he got back he was
punished he was punished by the
commanders of the army because he'd
endangered a spartan asset himself
he had endangered one of the assets of
the army by being so reckless with the
way that he went in so even somebody um
that's another control measure what
we're talking about here are uh control
measures whether they be
monotheistic gods that cause you to
emergently try and act in the way that
you think that you should whether they
be cctv cameras that dictatorially tell
you that if you do not act in the way
that you're supposed to whether they be
cultural norms that are kind of this
embodied sensed communitarian version of
this and you even have when somebody
oversteps that marker and somebody
utilizes their skill or their prowess
and is wasteful with it in a society
like sparta where it was all about
trying to get the most done trying to
squeeze everything you could out of a
small society even those uh soldiers
were told you can't endanger an asset
even if it's yourself
well listen i'll tell you i you know
i've been in a lot of combat with us
military and we were in a situation very
bad situation at one point up on a ridge
and the taliban
were on either side of us there was
nowhere to hide right and they were
about to open up on us
and uh there was no good place to be
right and the only chance we had was
by we i mean the soldiers i was with it
was to unleash so much firepower back at
them you know i mean we sort of hide by
behind our own firepower but eventually
you run out of ammunition right and so
it was extremely exposed place
uh everyone had run out of water it was
very hot so everyone was black on water
it's called black water they run out of
water they're drinking the fluid in
their iv bags so where people wounded
they wouldn't have iv fluid it was a
desperate situation we were getting
ready to get hit and it was gonna really
suck
and the lieutenant stood up
in this sort of awful
moment of quiet before we were gonna get
hit we could hear it on the icons on the
radio chatter from the enemy like okay
we've got them they have nowhere to hide
they are done right and we were waiting
for this
hurricane of lead right
and the the lieutenant stood up
uh i mean the only place you can be is
like on the ground as close to the
ground as possible so standing up in
this situation i can't tell you how hard
that would be to do right and the man
stood up to look around to see where his
heavy weapons were were positioned to
make sure that they were in the best
possible position again think connelly
in dublin in 1916.
he stood up to see where the heavy
weapons were were placed the 240s uh
particularly to make sure they were
placed right and the staff sergeant that
was right next to me
said
sir please sit down
we need you
we need you to stay alive
it's your job to make decisions it's our
job to get shot at
and the staff sergeant stood up he said
tell me what you need tell me what you
need to know and i'll find it out and
you take please take cover and so that's
exact that is leadership and when
corporations sometimes bring me in as a
consultant to like how to make their
corporation like feel more like a tribe
so that basically there's more like
group loyalty by the workers so they'll
produce more and everyone gets richer
right particularly the leadership uh
when they bring me in for that
consultation i say look
you have to be
a leader
a leader makes sure
that they may they may benefit
disproportionately when things go well
no problem right leadership should be
rewarded disproportionately as higher
responsibilities it takes more
experience etc etc
but if there's a downturn
and
people are going to make less or people
are going to have to be fired
the leadership
of this company
has to experience
the negative consequences before the
people they lead or at least with them
right so before you fire anybody
you have to get rid of your year-end
bonus right and if you don't
that's not leadership
that's
you're just running a company at that
point you're not leading a company
you're running a company if you keep
your year-end bonus and fire people
because there's a downturn in the market
you're just running a damn company
you're not leading it if you want to
lead it if you want loyalty you need to
lead it and if you lead it you will make
it clear that you will suffer
consequences right alongside the people
that are trusting you
not a welcome message in the corporate
world i should add yeah i bet it's not i
should
it makes me think about an example so i
run nightclubs i have done for a very
long time i've stood on the front door
of a lot of them
and
part of that
me and my business partner have been the
directors of this company since we were
18 we've always been the top of the tree
and then we've just added in people
below us all the way up
every single night that we run an event
one of us stands on the front door of
the nightclub and we're in newcastle
which is the winterfell of the uk right
it's the final city before scotland in
the winter it gets brutally cold it's
wet it's it's dark it's miserable
we stand on the front door of the night
every single one there has never been an
event that we've operated where somebody
hasn't stood there we have always been
there right next to the boys right next
to the event managers right next to the
door staff that kick people out and
we'll freeze our nuts off on the door
along with them and
for a long time people have asked what
is it that you do we don't do that much
the whole purpose of us creating a
business that runs in a slick and
organized way is that it's so
self-sufficient that everybody knows the
jobs that need doing beforehand and
there are a lot of nights where we stand
there and i feel like a spare part i'm
like well i'll just i'll just make sure
that the dj's drinks are topped up again
you almost end up doing the most sort of
surplus ridiculous jobs because there
isn't anything for you to do but it's
less about the fact that you're there to
do a job and it's more about the fact
that symbolically you are there with the
rest of the group look it's freezing
it's cold it's going to be a [ __ ]
thursday in the middle of january it's
we're going to do 400 people tonight
when we should do a thousand and that's
what break even's 500 people so we're
going to lose money and i'm going to get
out of bed at 10 p.m at night and i'm
going to stand on the front door of a
nightclub with you for five hours and
there's going to be drunk people and
they're going to complain but we're all
going to do it together
and a big part of that that we see as
well is
in small businesses like ours that's
quite hierarchical there's lots of
different little layers that we create
so people can progress and it feels like
they're being promoted and stuff
the guys that get the most respect to
the ones that people have seen enter the
company at the absolute bottom they
started flying and doing street pr and
giving out guest list bands trying to
get people in then they were the guest
best guest lister then they became a
junior event manager and they smashed it
at that then they became a full event
manager and they smashed it at that then
a senior then a city manager and people
see this lineage of them going up bit by
bit by bit and they know that they've
earned their stripes they know that they
have the chops to be able to do the
thing that they are telling you to do
they've done it i've done thousands and
thousands of knocks on doors we got to
the point where my knuckles were
bleeding during my uh gap year because i
was knocking on the doors of so many
different halls of residence to say hey
you coming out tonight hey you coming
out tonight so i've been there but the
only reason that i can tell my boys to
go and do that
is because i've done it as well i'm like
look this is a [ __ ] rite of passage
this is what you do if you want to get
to the stage where you can have your own
company or where you can be paid the
sort of money that you want to be paid
like step into the fire
yeah yeah absolutely i mean i mean right
you're signaling that you're part of the
group you're not outside it you're not
above it
and i was thinking
this morning actually i was sort of
what's the definition you know i wrote a
book called tribe you know it's hard to
define what a tribe is and
and
um some people think that oh if you're
uh you know football fans football fans
are all like one tribe they're not a
tribe right i mean they have they're a
group of people that have a common
interest but they're not a tribe in a
meaningful human sense and so the
definition i sort of came up with this
morning was
um
the idea of what happens to you happens
to me
we're in the same tribe because that's
true and
you were saying that to the people that
were working for you like if you got to
stand out there in the cold i'm going to
stand out there in the cold now i may be
completely useless
and if they say to you listen sir why
don't you get it go inside and get
warmed up it sucks out here we got this
like the lieutenant in my story
you then you you can honorably step down
right you can honorably say okay i i
understand thank you appreciate it right
um
uh i mean there's no merit in being
stupid either right yeah isn't it
interesting that that kind of has to be
gifted
from below it's not the sort of thing
that you can bestow upon yourself
but
i mean real leadership
is is is given from below right it's
it's by cons but despite cons the
consent of the lead
um
imposing leadership it really isn't
leadership right i mean that you know
when it's sort of imposed from above
and that's the problem with inherited
wealth it's not earned and you have a
huge amount of social and economic
capital
that can be imposed on other people and
it hasn't been granted by them and it ha
and
it hasn't been earned
and so but when the people that you're
leading
ask you to take care of yourself like we
need you
right
then you're good and it's because you
have signaled to them what happens to
you happens to me until you tell me
otherwise
right and then i will step inside and uh
whatever yeah exactly
whatever it may be and you know in the
in the marines
um there's a motto um
officers eat last right well in a
situation like that what you may well
have is enlisted men saying sir
you know please get a plate of food like
you know like we understand that
officers eat last we appreciate it now
can you please feed yourself you know we
you know we respect and admire you and
we want you to eat and you know so
that's the that's the honorable way to
do it and likewise connolly in dublin
you know his you know his it took his
aid sort of dragging him out of gunfire
uh you know to keep him safe he wasn't
gonna do it on his own
uh but he would do it for for others
one of the things that i've found that's
been quite interesting is how uh
stresses from the outside
uh cause groups to stick together so
when freedoms get threatened a community
suffers a collective trauma or whatever
people usually bind together
what i've found really interesting
is that i don't think we've seen that up
against the global threat of covid over
the last 18
months yeah i mean the problem with
covet is is
that there was a lot of mixed messaging
by political leaders
um i mean
my political leader at the time donald
trump
started by saying it didn't exist there
wasn't a threat at all right and then he
continued to have very confusing
messaging about masks and vaccines and
you know to the point where it's
completely hypocritical i mean the
entire administration was vaccinated and
so was all of fox news
and yet the messaging coming out of
those groups was that vaccinations were
somehow a plot by the left to take you
know whatever i mean just complete
nonsense right so when you have
uh political leadership and very
powerful people that are actually
um endangering the public
for their own political benefit
um
you're not going to have a healthy
response to to covet so i get that for
the usa but i don't think i've seen a
particular
wonderful sense of belonging and coming
together really anywhere on the planet
maybe you could argue that the
uh the usa are culturally so influential
that if they cough everybody else
catches a cold of covid of
misinformation perhaps um but there was
do you remember that video i think it
was in italy and there was someone
singing on a rooftop and there was
balconies all the way around and they
were all watching and there was another
period where maybe in spain or italy
again somewhere in europe someone was
doing a workout routine on their own
rooftop and all of the people on their
balconies overlooking that were doing it
as well now that to me that was one of
the moments where you go wow that's sort
of human spirits really binding together
everybody is in this yeah we know i know
what it's like to be locked down in the
uk yeah i don't live in new york the
same as you yeah my life situation is
different to yours but i kind of know
what it feels like to be locked in my
own house because of this pathogen
that's outside so we have more of a
shared experience now
than we probably ever did before and
it's the same for people that are in
china and in vietnam and in australia
and everywhere
there's always been that argument made
if earth was threatened by an alien
species imagine how quickly our
differences would be forgotten because
we would bind together and you get that
i think it's called is it the globe
effect that astronauts get once they've
been out to space and they view the
earth without borders and they come back
and they realize we are just one race
one species blah blah um i
hoped
18 months ago that kovid was going to be
that thing and it just
hasn't it doesn't seem to have occurred
anywhere
well it's not an existential threat
right i mean i mean it's it's way worse
than the flu it's a deadly disease
um
and it's communicable uh
you know unlike unlike some things but
but it's not it's not an existential
threat to society and you know i think
what the sort of skeptics were saying is
that the protections against covet are
an existential threat because they'll
[ __ ] the economy blah blah blah
that's where the debate happens but look
the black death in europe
um
in what was the 12th 13th 1300s 1200s
1300s killed one out of three people
right that's an existential threat right
and if covid were killing one out of
three thank god it wasn't but if it was
killing one out of three i think you
might have seen a sort of different
reaction but even to the extent we lost
we've lost 600 000 people in this in
this country right
um
but you know if you lose 600 000 people
during an alien attack
it'll traumatize the nation for a
century right like i mean that gets your
attention the problem with the 600 000
is to spread out spread out over a
couple of years and it's happening
invisibly in icus around the country
and it's in some ways it's sort of
theoretical sort of abstract and but
even despite all that and despite the
fact that we had to stay away from
people in order to protect people which
is deeply antithetical to sort of human
human reflexes during the crisis
but even so i think there was actually a
fair amount of sort of solidarity of the
of that sort that you described in new
york city people were i think it was at
5 00 p.m every night people were leaning
out of their windows banging pots and
pans for the healthcare workers that
were working in the in the ers in the
hospital so you know i think um
for a modern society that's very very
fractured and alienated there was
actually a fair amount of sort of like
communal sentiment around all of this
yeah it makes me
realize why false flag events
by governments have seemed alluring over
time
you know you look at trying to do a
thing trying to have some catastrophe
occur that forces that's what they're
actually doing they're trying to
artificially inseminate this sense of
binding together here is the threat
there is something happening out there
and we need to bind together we need you
to come together as one that's what
they're trying to enact
that's right and the problem is
they are right at least in my country
right now
um
they are politically they are doing that
with half the country they're saying
half the country is a threat to this
country
if you're a republican the democrats the
socialist communist godless
like black lives matter democrat
anarchists
are a threat to this country right so
they're what they're saying is that half
of the country are literally the enemy
right the enemy they're not the beloved
right they're not the definition of you
know freedom they're not they don't
deserve freedom they don't deserve to be
free they're the enemy right they're not
one of us
the democrats i don't think do it in the
same way and not as not as sort of
virulently as the republicans have
lately but they have a bit of that as
well and so when you when you cast your
own people
as the enemy of the state
you're you are creating civil war you
work that is one of the steps to fascism
right i mean that was a classic the one
a classic step in the fascist playbook
is take the political opponents and say
not only do i disagree with them
not only are they not nice people
they're actually an enemy of this
country and they must be eradicated and
that's how you get fascism it's a
classic classic move in the fascist
playbook and that's one of the things
that really bothers me about the last
few years in this country we have a very
robust democracy and we have a military
which is absolutely loyal to democratic
ideals whether it be a republican or a
democratic president they don't really
care
um my father grew up in spain and left
when when franco came franco and the
fascists came in and franco succeeded
because he had the military behind him
that will never happen in this country
and therefore
in my opinion fascism will never come to
this country but boy it's awfully ugly
to see the sort of preparatory steps in
action uh even if it will never come to
that it's crazy when you create in-group
out-group dynamics within a nation when
there's other things that need to be
worried about and this is i think
why
the people that have done research into
china and into russia and into sort of
long-term trajectories and concerns
about what's happening to the globe
that's the ones who are
you know
standing in the middle of the street
with a megaphone desperately saying look
there are bigger [ __ ] problems out
there there are really bigger problems
there's this quote from your book that
says
if the enemy is not going to show mercy
you might as well fight to the death
freedom as a supreme value was born out
of the fact that there were really no
alternatives worth considering and the
result was that the freest people were
the most warlike what that
sounds like is kind of a race to the
bottom or a race to
extreme extremity and when you have that
enacted against a another nation you end
up securing your own nation but when you
start to play this self-referential game
within a country
what you end up with is ever escalating
tensions
ever more malicious uh strategies in
order to be able to manipulate people
and make the other side seem like the
bad guys and make you seem like the good
guys and that's why it doesn't surprise
me again that we don't really know what
politicians think or what the truth is
or what's going on
yeah and you can read the word warlike
to mean uh best able to defend
themselves right and
um if you can't defend yourself you're
not gonna be free for very long these
enemy will come along and dominate you
and
uh
that was has been true for i think all
of human history
um and there's plenty of example of
examples but
the the great thing about democracy
is that it and international law is as
sort of as taking care of that problem
right there are coalitions of nations
that that have treaties
mutual defense packs so you you know you
you would you attack
belgium you're attacking the whole eu
you attack belgium you're attacking nato
right you're you know all of a sudden
you're attacking half the world and so
it keeps you know it has a state those
treaties have a stabilizing effect
um and and uh
you know i would say that the
um
when you when you cast
when you cast people as an enemy now
um
we're in a situation at least in america
we we really cannot plausibly and be
invaded by anybody right so when you
cast people as an enemy it's a pretty
much a sort of naked attempt to just
reinforce your political base there
really is not a threat to this country
not from the other political party not
from black lives matter
uh
not from china i mean their economic
threats but you know whatever but
they're but they're not a threat in the
sense that enemy is you the word is
usually taken
and
it's a it's a naked political ploy and
you know it really should be called out
because it is the beginning of the end
about of democracy it's it's going to
destroy it
sebastian younger ladies and gentlemen
freedom will be linked in the show notes
below
you are not on social media so there's
nothing else for people to keep up to
date with do you have a blog or a
website or anything
i have a website
sebastianyounger.com j-u-n-g-e-r is my
spelling of my name
uh my publisher started some social
media accounts for me um i have a flip
phone here i'll sew it i'll prove it i
have a flip phone i'm not interested in
social media
but um
uh i can't i've just got and i i hate
the idea of tweeting meaningful things
140 characters at a time but i have
taken two posting sentences from my book
freedom on twitter with with photographs
uh and sentences that often involve the
concept of freedom just for people to
share and debate so i do do that a
little bit i'm pretty easy to find that
way so
um thank you it was a pleasure talking
to you i really enjoyed it me too man
thank you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you